several days ago Justin Amash a
Republican congressman from the state of
Michigan took to Twitter to explain that
after reading the Muller report and
that's important he came to the
conclusion that Donald Trump did in fact
commit impeachable offenses and that
Attorney General William bar did in fact
mislead everyone in this country about
what was actually in the Muller report
well obviously Donald Trump was not too
happy about a fellow Republican saying
that this guy could be impeached for
what he's done and Trump lashed out on
Twitter with the following series of
tweets here he said never a fan of at
Justin Amash a total lightweight who
opposes me and some of our great
Republican ideas and policies just for
the sake of getting his name out there
through controversy if he had actually
read the biased mullah report composed
by 18 angry dims who hated Trump he
would see that it was nevertheless
strong on no collusion and ultimately no
obstruction anyway how do you obstruct
when there is no crime and in fact the
crimes were committed by the other side
Justin is a loser who sadly plays right
into our opponents hands I didn't know
it was even possible to squeeze in that
much misinformation and though that many
lies into a single tweet but the
president somehow managed to do it first
and foremost his claims of no collusion
the report specifically comes to the
conclusion that because of all the lies
told to Robert Muller and the
investigators by the Trump
administration and by the Trump campaign
they weren't able to continue chasing
leads they had been lied to so much that
they could not reach a definitive
conclusion on collusion as for the
obstruction they lay that out pretty
clearly there was obstruction Muller
just didn't want to be the one to indict
the president because he was still
working off that outdated and completely
false
DOJ memo from decades ago that says you
can indict a sitting president
you actually can legal scholars agree
you 100% can there's nothing wrong with
it there's no precedent to say you can't
Muller just wanted to say okay that
that's up to you you go ahead and do
this Justice Department and then William
bar obviously comes out with his little
four
CliffsNotes version of this and says no
if everything's cool we're good to go
we're not gonna press charges
let's all move on which is exactly what
William Barr was hired to do Justin
Amash did unlike Trump claims read the
report and what's really interesting to
me is that in his series of tweets where
he spelled this out there was one thing
that stuck out to me the most and he
said that it was the pattern of behavior
the Muller report established a pattern
of behavior of criminal activity by
Donald Trump now any good prosecutor in
this country understands that when
you're prosecuting somebody the first
thing you want to establish is a pattern
of behavior to say that this is how this
person has lived their life they broke
the law here they did it here they did
it here they did it here and they're
doing it now and that's why they're in
court if you can establish that pattern
it's much easier to get a conviction and
Republican representative Amash here
says that the pattern exists Muller laid
out that pattern for us we know it's
real we know it happened the big problem
here is that obviously this doesn't
change anything just because we have one
Republican joining the impeachment train
doesn't suddenly mean we're going full
steam ahead Nancy Pelosi you know
Speaker of the House of Representatives
has made it clear that's not the path
she wants to go right now
so we're stuck it also doesn't mean
there's going to be an avalanche of more
Republicans saying yes that's a great
idea let's impeach that ain't going to
happen
and even if it does happen it's only
gonna happen in the House of
Representatives where we could already
impeach without a single Republican vote
but you're not gonna get the ones in the
Senate
I applaud congressman Amash for putting
country over party
unfortunately there's not enough
Republicans willing to do that I'm fair
and cousins and for David Pakman we'll
be right back if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video